the 63rd annual Academy Awards is being
brought to you by
JCPenney where fashion comes to life
Royal Caribbean the grand resorts of the
seven seas kodacolor gold film showed
your true colors and the coca-cola
company and your local coca-cola bottler
probably no area of film technology has
made as much progress as visual effects
with the exception of those drink
holders in the theater isn't that like
the greatest thing that's like a great
thing because I'm older I can't reach
underneath for the guy's feet from
behind me is there and I like the drink
holders it's not funny but I just wanted
to say I like to drink holder thing and
here is one of the first uses of special
effects on film dates back to 1900 the
name of this film was a terrible Turkish
executioner and for its time it was a
real stomach turner watch this
that footage was approved by Iraqi
censors to present the award for visual
effects if you thought Madonna was
exciting here is a showstopper in his
own way the President of the Motion
Picture Association of America mr. Jack
Valenti
this year the Academy has determined
that the visual effects on one
particular film was of such a remarkably
high order that it deserved to be
singled out for special recognition
and here except accepting the award for
visual effects for Total Recall or Eric
Brevik Rob butene Tim McGovern and Alex
Fung
I'd like to thank you director Paul
Verhoeven and everyone at dream quest
images also thanks to Industrial Light
and Magic for their help and a personal
thanks to Don Brevik and my wife fairy
I'd like to thank all the people that
made this dream come true I'd like to
thank Ron she said and especially my big
brother and mentor Rick Baker I salute
you presentation here is two-time Oscar
winner might lead Uggla's